so I've never driven a car blind before
but here we go you're gonna bag today
we're going to try something I've been
wanting to do for a while it's an idea I
had called video game simulator for
Enders messing around this little tiny
loop drone and we thought it'd be funny
like run around behind with the camera
as a third-person video game camera
angle so I decided to take it probably a
couple steps too far and I built this
rig here where has a little
radio-controlled camera the battery and
all the transmitters as well as the
GoPro right here so I can record it
somebody's going to put the goggles on
they're going to run a Grand Theft Auto
obstacle course here while they can only
see themselves from third-person camera
view I have made Sam volunteer I have no
idea what's going on I thought I could
see myself
you let watch us try it out so your
framing is pretty [ __ ] right now
it's canted making me kind of there we
go that's better up or down down that's
better yeah I think you are right there
you're a little bit off there yeah this
isn't a challenge for me so much as it
is for Niko
give me a little crazy so we're going to
do in this GTA simulator Sam is going to
have to mug Ren steal his keys in the
car Jack the car driving about 40 feet
down this big empty street hop out and
then kill the one opposing gang member
with a nerf gun just like GTA you didn't
say anything about our okay let's just
do it I'm just lucky let's go you know
what course he was like as it real life
was GPA I I'm ready to do it let's go we
are loading in I come in to peep out
they're going to go live there you just
got what's the circle [ __ ]
mm geez I got him
so I've never driven a car blind before
but I can see the whole car right now I
can't see the dashboard warning signals
anything but here we go
this little weird oh my god I can't see
anything there's a car passing during
left casino and I'm gonna stop I'm gonna
know I'm not gonna rent yeah let me have
someone coming up here rent yep oh yeah
all right I think the cars off right
Hey
oh I get it the dead
here we go think of money
okay off those old chaotic I love it
though
how was it dance you shot me right in
the forehead right here keeping up the
cars really hard
I started going a little faster than we
discussed it did feel like GTA I'm going
to try operating the camera and give
Nikko a chance I'm going to try and make
a few improvements on the camera work
make it so it's even easier for Nikko to
get run in the bulb I'm legit nervous
all right cool do it it's a rent easy
ready to load in yeah what's your
character's name every g4 20 loading in
go for it
what's really hard
oh he's moving
oh my god this is so intense it's
actually it's easier than walking though
like I can actually see where we going
just fine but I can totally see where my
cars pointing all right
my voice
if I'm off-center the third-person
camera I can't just flick the thumbstick
forwards and make myself frustrated
again I'd like basically turn my body
and go in the new direction and see what
happens
I think we should up the steak GTA
online style so I actually built another
one of these poles they have another set
of goggles so we can do 1v1 third-person
camera GTA fighting it's going to be
really janky let's do it wait alright we
ran up the stakes here for the very end
Sam and I are going to be cameramen and
they're going to be picking our soldiers
Sam I will give you a first pick between
Rennes and Jimmy Oh Jimmy let's do this
yeah amigo we are going to equip both
Jimmy and Ren with nerf guns whoever
shoots the other person the most by the
time that empties our Meg wins the fight
the winner gets the ham bone char know
all your money bad or you lose it and
it's good but squeezing the pot landing
the Ren fights the best when he's
bleeding so we made sure to save himself
up before we got started if we're going
to crush this and Ren's going to get all
the ham bones when you're in your gun
make sure it's a big obvious motion that
I can like aim down the gun a little bit
okay alright I'm going to plug right in
to be looking right down your iron sight
okay okay I'll just walk around like
this yep or you can just go like horses
and I'll be like directly behind you
like that this time we're going to show
you guys the GoPro footage because it's
a lot cleaner and I sort of look at all
right they're ready
go
Oh game over guys game over good it was
good once I got my bearing turns out I'm
just the best I would have to hit him oh
wow you also got a direct link for it my
solid Jimmy got our head shot on Rena
net so that's a win in my book right
there yeah
Randy knows a nice try you hit me once
right in the hand just once
yeah just one ring do you want those ham
bones yeah we can probably talk to Musa
one more round if we swapped and I've
talked for you I'll probably do a much
better camera jumping needed good night
I'm not going to argue with that your
house I'm going to notice not a little
great camera man three two one
the color here in Scituate boiling down
into cover oh let's go around
I got broke the runway the camera by a
Norris dam alright alright Thank You
creamy yogurt all right that was great
yes technical difficulties with the ends
day honor one I don't think this book
cop got all fun Duke you're friends with
the rear camera set up fishing so go
home and say I was the winner right yeah
yeah you beat me first when you thought
of this little video game simulator
experiment I got some other cool ideas
we'll try down the line ID scroller
simulator like Mario salars who is
running spider to the camera while you
have goggles on and jump over [ __ ] takes
your phone again to throw up
yes really everything like I could be
like a Koopa shell and a Stabler coming
I do a jump over it but you won't be
able like actually judge refused it
that's one where we actually wear the
helmet yeah we do Mario and Luigi Albert
baby think well you're going to make
another hand going jar after that one
yeah definitely